I saw Dana man I was at a fight in Vegas
yeah I walked in the back Joe Rogan was
happy to see me
you know that makes me feel and then I
saw Dana he was like what's up man I was
like oh I want to come back and he was
like
I was like what bro like what is that
what'd he saying he just made her look
I was like I want to come back man and
this is actually Michael's on a page
fight no this was before see don't have
a different ball game now you're in
different Stratosphere I was still
winning I know but not Michael Ben and
Paige yeah come on now Bellator what's
up I'll fight Venom page in bellatorian
MMA why hasn't this been talked about
because I was strangle him